uh let me ask you in terms of that kid
in the garage or those couple of kids in
the garage what advice would you give to
them if they want to start a new social
network or
a business what advice would you give to
somebody with a big dream and a young
startup
to me you have to choose to do something
that even if it fails like you you it
was so fun right like
we never started instagram knowing it
was going to be big we started instagram
because we loved photography we loved
social networks i had seen what other
social networks had done and i thought
hmm
maybe we did a spin on this but like
nowhere was our fate predestined like it
wasn't like
it wasn't written out anywhere that
everything was going to go great and i
often think that counterfactual like
what if it had not gone well i would
have been like i don't know that was fun
we raised some money we learned some
stuff and
and does it position you well for the
next experience
that's the advice that i would give to
anyone wanting to start something today
which is like
does this meet with your ultimate goals
not wealth not fame none of that because
all of that by the way is [ __ ] like
you can get super famous and super
wealthy and
i like i think generally those are not
things that
again it's easy to say with like a lot
of money that somehow like it's not good
to have a lot of money it's just
i think that complicates life enormously
in a way that people don't fully
comprehend so i think it's way more
interesting to shoot for can i make
something that people love that provides
value in the world that i love building
that i love working on that i write
that's um
that's what i would do if i were
starting from scratch and by the way
like in some ways that i will do that
personally which is like choose the
thing that you get up every morning
you're like i
love this
even when it's painful
even when it's painful what about a
social network specifically if you were
to imagine
put yourself in the mind of something
compete against myself i can't give out
ideas okay
no but it's like high level like focus
on community yeah
and yeah
i i said that as a as a half joke um in
all honesty i think these things are so
hard to build that like ideas are a dime
a dozen
but um
you have to talked about keeping it
simple
can i tell you which is a liberating
idea that model is yes it's three
circles and they overlap one circle is
uh what do i have experience at slash
what am i good at i don't like saying
what am i good at because it just like
seems like
what do i have experience in right what
can i bring to the table what am i
excited about is the other circle what
gets it what's just super cool right
that i want to work on because even when
this is hard
i think it's so cool i want to stick
with it
and the last circle is like what does
the world need
and if that circle ain't there it
doesn't matter what you work on because
there are a lot of startups that exist
that just no one needs or very small
markets need
but if you want to be successful i think
if you're like if you're good at it you
have it sorry if you're good at it if
you're passionate about it and the world
needs it i mean this sounds simple but
not enough people sit down and just
think about those circles and think
do these things overlapping can i get
that middle section it's small but can i
get that middle section
um i think a lot about that personally
and then you have to be really honest
about the circle that you're good at
and really honest about the circle
that uh the world needs
and i suppose
really honest about the passion like
what you actually love yeah as opposed
to like some kind of dream of making
money all those kind of stuff like
literally love dude i had a former
engineer who decided to start a startup
and i was like are you sure you want to
start a company versus like join
something else
because um
being a coach of an mba team and playing
basketball are two very very different
things
and like not everyone fully understands
the difference
i think you can kind of do it both
um
and i don't know jury's out on that one
because like they're in the middle of it
now so but it's really important to
figure out what you're good at not be
full of yourself like truly look at your
track record
um what's the saying like it ain't
bragging if you could if if you can do
it um
but too many people
are delusional and and like think
they're better at things than they
actually are or think there's a bigger
market than there actually is just
when you confuse your passion for things
with a big market that's really scary
right like just because you think it's
cool doesn't mean that it's a big
business opportunity so like what
evidence do you have again i'm a fairly
like i'm a strict rationalist on this
and like sometimes people don't like
working with me because i'm pretty
pragmatic about things like i'm not
i'm not elon like i don't sit and make
bold proclamations about visiting mars
like that's just not how i work
i'm like okay i want to build this
really cool thing that's fairly
practical i think we could do it and
it's in this way and what's cool though
is like that's just my sweet spot i'm
not like
i just i can't i can't with a straight
face talk about the metaverse i can't i
just it's not me
what do you think about the the facebook
renaming it
and that is a dick i just listen i know
like i'm i'm fairly
i like to live in the next five years
and like what what things can i get out
in a year that people will use at scale
and
um
so it's just again those circles i think
are different for different people but
it's important to realize that like
market matters
you being good at it matters and having
passion for it matters
you